Now in Android studio,
you can hit the play button
to run the app on your device.
In the device Chooser dialog,
you should see your connected device.
To prevent the dialog from popping up
in future times, check this box,
and then hit OK to continue.
Within a few moments,
you should see it on your phone.
On the other hand,
as Raido was mentioning,
you can use command line tools.
>From the root folder of the project,
use grade lw to build your app
on Mac or Linux.
Check the link in the notes below
if you're using Windows.
This first command grants
execution permission
to the gradlw rappers script.
And you only need to do it the first time
you're trying to build
from the command line.
Then you can call grade lw assemble debug.
Once the build is successful,
it creates an APK file
at the app/build/apk directory.
You can use adb to install the app.
The -r command means
that you can replace an existing version
of the app if you've
already done it before.
For more tips on adb, you can see
the instructor notes below.
Then you can use this adb command
with the activity manager tool
in order to start the main activity.
And there you see it on the device.
And now we see it running
in our phones.
Woo hoo! Fist bump!
We're on a roll. Let's go find Dan so that
we can build up the sunshine UI. Woo!